[Music]
today
we are announcing that texas will build
a border wall in our state
to help secure our border make no
mistake
the border crisis that we're dealing
with right now is a direct result
of the open border policies that have
been put into place by the by the
administration
homes are being invaded neighborhoods
are
dangerous and people are being
threatened
on a daily basis we believe in the rule
of law and law and order in this state
and by god we're going to step up and
deliver that rule of law and law and
order in the state of faith
an impassioned texas governor greg
abbott taking the crisis at the border
into his own hands
committing millions to build the border
wall and protect his state
this comes as the governor also
announces he's emptying out a state
prison
to house illegal immigrants with low
level offenses
joining us with more texas congressman
and house finance committee member
lance gooden welcome congressman thank
you
so texas is stepping up texas is saying
we're not going to take this if the
federal government's not going to do it
we're going to do it ourselves can texas
do
it texas can do it we did this
in the years of the obama administration
not build a wall
but enforce immigration law we had a
really great four years of president
donald trump
actually doing what the president should
be doing and that is
protecting and defending our nation
including at the border and
it's amazing what can happen in six
months since january
the border has basically been open our
own vice president who is in charge of
this crisis according to the president
hasn't even been to the border
we have a severe crisis on the texas
border
and all the way to california and our
governor stepping up and saying
we need to do something we need to build
a wall and not only are people
supportive of that in texas but
there's enough land from volunteers to
even build most of this wall between
state land
and land owners giving up their land to
this border wall effort
there's an outpouring of support along
our southern border and i think it's
great and i'm proud of our governor for
doing it we'd love to see it i want to
ask about the other aspect of it as well
so they're not
closing they're not letting people out
of the state prison they're moving it
elsewhere so they can allocate this
prison
for illegals who have already broken the
law by coming here illegally but also
have committed other crimes
what what's that change um it's
it's it's a change in the sense that
it's so sad that we even have to do this
we have been overrun by crossings
of people that we we can't contain we've
got children
i've asked this administration what
they're doing with children how are we
making sure
that these children are not being
trafficked are they really coming over
with their parents are they being
trafficked by cartel members i have
introduced a bill
to require dna testing at the border to
determine whether or not the trafficker
or the parent
whoever they say they are is that really
them but with respect to this prison
this is just one of many things i think
you'll see in the months to come
if we don't get this under control and
it doesn't seem to be trending that way
which is why our governor and our state
legislature
have said here in texas that we've got
to do something ourselves
congressman i want to ask you about big
tech big tech seems to be a topic that
at least some out there think
might be a place where republicans and
democrats can work together
and this is because president joe biden
has
picked as head of the ftc lena khan
she's now been approved by the senate
and she's been a big critic
of big tech so that again brings up the
question can republicans and democrats
work on this together
i have to tell you i'm a bit skeptical
because it seems like we're coming at it
from different angles republicans
worried about censorship
and democrats under the guise of
disinformation looking for more
censorship
is there commonality anywhere i think
there is commonality
rarely would you see people getting
excited about a
people on the conservative side getting
excited about a liberal ftc chairwoman
but
lindsey graham josh hawley are some of
the many senators that crossed over and
voted for her confirmation i'm excited
to see what she has
going with respect to breaking up
monopolies and ensuring that they don't
grow
these bills that you're referencing that
i was a part of this week they're
bipartisan
the head of the progressive caucus miss
jayapal in washington and i
are working on a bill together i never
thought i would work on a bill with her
but we are and the goal is to prevent
these
growing monopolies from getting larger
yes there are different
motivations on the democrat side and my
side
but i think if the end result is we have
large companies that control
less of our lives then we will get to
the point where censorship
is not happening in the way that it is
no one would care
if facebook monitored president donald
trump if president donald trump had
another
avenue to go down with respect to social
media but because
facebook is so big it's really important
that they've banned him i
envision a dream scenario where someday
there's actual competition so if
facebook bans me
i don't care because i can go somewhere
else and that's what these bills seek to
do
they seek to increase a free market
and lessen the reliance on one or two
companies that are so big
that they dominate our lives it would be
great to see
we shall we shall see if anything like
that is truly possible in today's
capitol hill
representative lance gooding thank you
so much for your time appreciate it
thank you congressman thank you